warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised
who
Y and Crown the
witch euro vision song festival is known
for some pretty interesting crazy
performances I mean and this is
attracting millions and millions of
people right
but this one contestant from Ireland
Bambi Thug wow we're going to talk about
it today we're going to react to this
video Let's dive in okay so what strikes
me anyway right there is that even
before we see any imagery behind her
she's just on her knees like that um
pulsing back and forth oh as though she
is already in some way being Hol by a
demon P by spirits of some kind uhhuh um
she's wearing the demon the devil horns
yep and if that's not enough like on her
forehead they're up like antlers with
her headdress so that's what I see so
far what what does the antlers mean um
the antlers can also be somewhat of a
form it sounds really weird but it's
kind of like baffet it's just not the
horns of a goat and sometimes in the um
Celtic um Norse mythology the gods would
wear antlers or horns to symbolize that
they somehow were a God or maybe
worshiping Beth and the devil yeah
wow just for one second and let's let's
keep
watching okay
PA so this is one of the basics of
Witchcraft which she seems to be just
blatantly showing uhhuh is sitting in
the middle of a pentagram which you can
see there it's coming up it's yeah it's
going to be coming up a little more
obviously but then you light the candles
usually whether it's one or several
she's surrounded by candles but that
Circle of of candles also okay when you
go to cast a spell or do a ritual in the
wiccan um religion or just magic you
have to create your circle and that's
like your Sacred Space of casting which
is supposed to protect you from demons
but funny enough it invokes demons so
it's like you're dealing with the devil
yeah so that's what I'm seeing crazy and
this is people this is at the yours
Vision Song Festival there's like
thousands and thousands of people in the
crowd there's millions of people
watching from home all over Europe This
is like a family tradition every year
and this is what's happening there and
we're going to look at her official
music video after this that has over a
million views this is
nuts oh wow okay so what is she doing
here
she's she's mumbling almost like a chant
like that's what you're supposed to do
as well uh usually as you cast The
Circle you start calling the Four Winds
of the elements and water fire earth air
and the fifth one would be Spirit which
is what the pentagram stands for the
Five Points stands for those different
elements and once you do that you can
also call upon um gods and goddesses
names to invoke them as Demons Inside of
you or an object perhaps or something
but she's
kindly what she say but I that's what
she's doing
interes so there's another character
being introduced okay can you pause it
so it's like she in the very beginning
even when she was in that kind of
superhero pose with her hand out right
looking very smiling yeah she's this
evil smile well pop it up on the screen
it's like she's reveling in the power
that she's going to have all of a sudden
over this demon which I'm assuming that
that guy that pops up is a demon she's
still holding her hand out as though
she's just loving this now where we're
paused here what is the spiraling things
that she's wearing you know we'll get
into this a little more but the spirals
usually do come from the Celtic Faith
again it's like their Trinity that they
have there's also three on there yeah
and it's just that's all I know is that
it's the Trinity and they usually show
it as the um Celtic crop Al it's not
shown here it's just a bunch of spirals
that are going on of powers let's keep
watching let's see what this guy is all
about
mhm oh wow so she goes like this which
is usually even in dance it means you're
being taken over by it yeah and so you
were a hip-hop dancer so you you know
about these things so why do you do that
in dance in that you're fully giving
over to the movement at the and the
impulse of what's over what's overtaking
you in the music and it's usually it is
demonic or spiritual um and just to let
yourself sway into it and in this case
we definitely know what on Earth is
over yeah it's pretty obvious and then
they're still showing this other guy
once in a while and so she's holding her
hands up and all this stuff she's
obviously the one controlling him right
now mhm invoking him he's coming and
soon we'll see where he comes and that's
closer to her but
that's what is going on right now
okay wait oh so what's on her face what
is the the Three Little Dot thingies I
think that's another one of those um
Celtic kind of symbolisms that's going
on there they look like spirals as well
so she has them all over yeah yeah and
that face I mean just to hold your hands
out like that and just have a face I
hate to say this but like Beyonce when
she dances and you know that she's doing
Sasha Fierce yep which she says her alra
ego but really we know that's just demon
possession right and myself having
danced and and somewhat lost control on
stage I I don't remember what I was
doing so dancing I remember having lots
of faces that were very ugly and
actually very angry like that coming
across my face in moments like that so
she's doing it really well I hate to say
that but she's embodying this uh um
demonic channeling that she seems to be
um showing that she wants to do with
this pentagram and the circle and um
yeah
crazy okay so you have the chanting and
the breathing which sounds so Eerie yeah
but you have that within the chanting
that witches start doing in that Circle
right so it does is kind of like uh just
creepy
[Applause]
oh there's the other guy okay so she
thinks she's in control right now but as
we know I hope people do know this that
as you get into messing with the occultt
world you are chanting and you are
trying to manifest or give a spell or
chant on the universe or these demons to
have your will be done MH they might
give you what you want a lot of times
they do but it usually backfires and
they end up controlling you right this
reminds me of of the movie I've never
seen it but Mikey told me about it um
the craft have you seen it mhm and they
do the exact same thing there's these
teenagers that they're like oh we're
just going to dive delve into Witchcraft
and it'll be fun and we'll get whatever
we want and then it backfired and they
got full on into it and everything went
wrong and dark and evil and they were
like yikes we need to get out of this
right but while it's going on you do get
a lot of what you want you think oh my
goodness everything's going my way she
seems like she's again just loving this
like I'll just speak in dominance and um
obedience in obedience to me everything
will come to fruition that I want yeah
so this demon on my behalf I'll just ask
him for what I want that's what I'm
getting at least in the imagery here he
will do it because I have that power
over him
[Applause]
interesting so here here it changes to
the Moon right it was all dark and the
music slows down and there's a moon
behind her I know you told me there's
some interesting
um symbolism symbolism when it comes to
the Moon yes so in oh my
goodness what do you want to call this
the occult world or directly down into
Satanism there's what is usually the
male and female parts of of symbolism
and the god being becoming a god
yourself that is the male side which is
usually the sun it's represented of the
Sun and then the female part is usually
the Moon so I'm not sure um but she
seems to be all of a sudden calming down
and becoming more feminine all of a
sudden striking that pose right here yes
and she also if you've noticed has
switched the control of the dancing has
all all of a sudden become the Demon's
will he has the hands on her wrist and
it's just kind of spinning her around in
this ballet type thing and what I find
interesting too is that this guy is uh
half his body is blue and half his body
is just his skin color like and he
flipped around when the moon came up so
it's like he has those two sides like
you were saying he has I'm going to give
you what you want side and now I'm
controlling you side yes and actually
the Dark Side of him is when he's
controlling her mhm mhm very
interesting oh and he has he has devil
horns okay so yep there's the horns
there I just want to mention this but
usually there's this as they were um
going into that dip mhm it usually does
feel as though you're dancing in tandem
with evil dancing with the devil how
many T times we seen that come up in
movies that statement Dare To Dance with
the Devil uh Batman uh which one was it
Batman The Dark Knight right and uh I
recently saw a video uh it was a the
show uh scream Queens where the devil
texted Ariana Grande who was playing his
character and says Dare To Dance with
the Devil it comes up mhm but it usually
so she seems to be liking it right now
everything's going smoothly and fun and
just happy and then all of a sudden
we'll just see what happens but I'm
guessing since he's in control it's
usually deceitful kind of dance of just
haah everything's good and then it
usually blows up total chaos
[Music]
yeah okay
whoa so he just undressed her and now
she's looking down like what just
happened and also she has a panogram on
her chest yeah which I don't know like
in some ways it's like she was shocked
by that that he was just doing what he
wanted with
her exposed her like that and she's like
oh okay
[Music]
so he's coming up behind her mhm and now
everything's red
yeah okay so here comes the sun uh-huh y
yeah so and things are getting warmer
like the red color and she's saying it's
it's slow dance at least I heard
something about a dance so it is kind of
like they're moving in tandem together
but it's starting to heat up it's
starting to get kind of weird mhm and
Sun uh the sun is is very well known in
occultism as as Sun worship M um
pretty much every single Pagan religion
uh has Sun worship included in it
mhm oh there it is okay so he's starting
to fully possess her right yeah there's
no control and she's like yeah so it's
happening like this the male aggression
and dominance of the sun if you want to
look at it that way with the occult
symbolism is there right so the sun is
male the Moon is female MH mhm okay
oh
what it was a slight scream and I know
that that sounds weird but if you are
possessed and you think of someone who
is fully getting into that yeah you can
usually just hear a slight if not very
strong shriek of demonic possession so
it sounded a little bit like that yeah
so she threw him off mhm and now they
are dancing
separately oh okay so I hate to say this
but like from my experience again of
dancing usually when you are giving into
that feeling of like I'm
great and I am somewhat God and you just
you you dance in tandem with the devil
if you will or evil and you know you're
doing it but you're happy about it like
everything she's starting to strike all
these poses just like yes mhm
it's like
they're W whoa so now she is enveloping
this aggression of just pure
like control I'm you know what I'm
thinking I don't even know if her scream
that she's doing right now is humanly
possible possible to be honest with you
yeah yeah that's what I was wondering is
if in her music she actually gives more
inhuman screams than normal
right but she's yeah she's definitely
controlling him now yeah she's
controlling him and she's fully absorbed
whatever power he was giving her before
mhm and he looks possessed now
mhm
who
Y and Crown The Witch and you know
what's sad how many people are laughing
and clapping well there's some people
who look a little bit uncomfortable but
like how many people are like yo that is
awesome dude like sick as anything and
it's
like do you know what you're playing
with I mean seriously mhm and I might
add that this is where I personally got
a lot of confidence from that moment and
it does it makes you very powerful
feeling although you realize eventually
that it's something it's very very um
demonic for sure and it's not godly yeah
and I had to stop relying upon that
power and that kind of confidence to be
given to me by music and so she looks
like she's going with it and a lot of
actors and actresses might not be music
it might be the moment on stage of the
praise they're getting but it does the
same thing it boosts your ego so much
that you feel like you can't do any
wrong let's look at this music video
Let's see what she does in here because
this is pretty sickening too
so thunder thunder is used a lot in in
Greek mythology to represent certain
Gods so for example Zeus was a God that
uh they say fell from the sky and there
was you know lightning thunder uh and
and Zeus if you really look into him is
actually representative of Satan that's
right unfortunately I have a lot to say
already okay about this go for it okay
what are we seeing so she's from Ireland
right yep that's the seat of Celtic
mythology okay you see the Celtic cross
right there already it's kind of
interwoven in certain things here
Christian cross too which is strange yes
and there's the pentagram underneath it
yes it says Blaze Bible yes and in that
way I'm going to go ahead and say that
this is her Grim War Book it's your
spellcasting book as a witch oh and when
you have the candles around you on some
kind of surface that's um up and you
have other items around it we see
several items that even I can't tell
what they are you said earli like a
medallion or something yeah she has like
a necklace or Medallion here y but then
there's a candle she has a a blue rose
um usually do have items of nature cuz
you're going to be calling the powers of
the universe and nature and the elements
into your casting okay and so it seems
as though we're looking at her altar
yeah and what is this is like an animal
or something in the back it it looked
like a ceramic uh rabbit looking up to
the sky which is strange you can usually
use any item that means something to you
okay interesting they call it a Bible
mhm and she's using it to cast spell so
let's see what happens now this video we
have to pause like a thousand times uh
because the imagery flashes by so
quickly but please bear with us this is
going to be pretty
interesting so she picks up the Bible oh
and here are two uh Ouija board piece oh
yes they use to cast to invoke the
spirits it's divination yeah y okay okay
so she's writing in her book um now here
in the corner it says wish I could take
back all the time
you were inside me by so when we went
through this it seemed like she was
talking about a an ex-boyfriend or
something at the same time this is so
super demonic this is so super invoking
Spirits I wouldn't be surprised if she's
talking about Satan or some Demon that
was inside of her note to self hex
exboyfriend make new boyfriend
boyriend oh make new better boyfriend so
what you are saying here is that that
she's writing down a spell right yeah
and she even says it right there it's
amazing that she put it but hex's are
spells or or curses you're actually
going to pronounce on someone okay or
something and um so she's creating her
own spell right now or a goal I guess
she's she's putting on paper her goals
okay like a vision board they use vision
boards a lot actually it's a different
kind of vision board yeah and um she's
writing it in this Frenzy
of just purpose like tons of purpose and
intention and you see the Flames
flickering as though it is actually
Conjuring up demons already like they're
listening like in the flame this is
creepy as
anything yeah
smiles she had a pentagram tattoo in her
hand oh we actually read she's pouring
salt okay here we go I believe that's
salt or sand salt in
alchemy Alchemy is part of witchcraft
yes and using chemic chemicals and
chemistry basically but you believe you
actually become this other chemical and
so when you pour and you're casting a
circle that's what she's doing she's
pouring the salt into her Circle same as
what we saw in the live performance
standing in a circle yes and for certain
rights or rituals in different times
whether they choose to use it or not
they will use the salt to do that in
their Circle or not so you could just
draw a circle in the sand or something
with a stick I can
AF oh there comes the voodoo doll
mhm oh my
gosh okay she's doing all kinds of
things to this doll and pouring stuff on
it of course we without getting into all
of it that is part of Witchcraft it's
what you have to do yeah to get these
things to happen there's always a order
of strange things you have to do to
invoke that demon to have your will done
mhm and
um it's just strange cuz she's having
pleasure from it again she's just like
yeah let's do this hex and the music
says even a hex for this and hex for
that and so I heard that just like she's
just plopping it everywhere yeah and
again this is a song she was performing
at the Eurovision song festival in front
of millions oh I was going to touch on
that when she was burning the
sage I hope you guys know this burning
sage is only used in Shaman type
witchcraft or Satan satanic occult
situations um
for channeling demons or having a
certain energy in your house and so on
like you you don't use it for any other
reason so she's doing that to help in
this
spellcasting and when she goes visually
with her dancing she just stops and it's
like she's um vibrating all of a sudden
it you clearly get the image that she's
finally invoked that demon fully it's
there inside of her and she just kind of
like freezes and looks up to the sky and
just lows it
in man guys pray for her right we're not
making this video because we're trying
to put her down making this video to
show you what's going on in the world
and that we need to be careful with what
we watch and listen to and that these
are the signs of the times that that the
Jesus is coming back soon we need to be
on our guard we need to be ready but
also let's pray for her she really needs
Jes
[Music]
Jesus so what she's in the
bathtub she's it looks like she's going
to drown her little voodoo doll that's
her
exboyfriend oh there you
go oh okay the power of her spell is on
fire all of a sudden her book and her
spell is on fire and she's got all this
jelly mucus stuff coming out of the
bathtub like things are actually
happening it's it's creating life it's
having power wow
and and so she says right here where we
paused I guess you'd rather have a star
than the moon anger so she's almost
saying you'd rather have me be angry
like a star a male like the male
aggression part of usually the gods or
goddesses like they used to say um in
all the idols that they worshiped it was
always this incurring the Wrath of the
god which was the male part right rather
than the the fale like kind and passive
so yeah she's almost saying like Okay
here we go you incurred my wrath I was
being nice before and now I'm not going
to be
[Applause]
wow okay so all of a sudden the music
slowed down and she is
outside with the moon so this is the
female part right having that moon on
her head as well which is also kind of
being more you know as most people would
say I guess more reflective and
emotional so she's just sitting there
kind of like oh man I lost my boyfriend
and she's going back into her emot of
like I miss him you know what I find
interesting this is just a quick
observation these colors are the exact
colors of transgenderism the transgender
flag I
mean I don't believe in coincidence in
music video production or in Hollywood
because every you don't sit there and
like um I guess I'm going to wear pink
and blue today like no there's
actually uh you know a lot of thought
that goes behind this and especially
look at how much symbolism she puts in
her videos there's no chance this was
just by accident right and she's wearing
a blue hair thing I don't know what to
call that but a wig yeah but on the top
of it it also has either Two Moons that
are connected but also can look like um
horns again yep so I don't know she's
just always paying hmage to Baff it
absolutely as
well oh and she's back yeah so she's
back like she's like there's literally a
demon speaking through her it's pretty
bizarre right and so you do get pulled
back and forth usually by the demons
you're invoking not from my experience I
don't know any of that but I've read
lots of encounters that witches have had
and they say I was fully in control and
the next moment I wasn't I was being
controlled as though I was observing
myself and so I've actually on top of
that and I mean no offense but there's a
lot of um statistics actually on this
that when you are either
dealing which with witchcraft or the
occult usually there's a multiple
personality problem going on and mental
illness is a huge problem oh that's
really sad um so it seems as though she
is actually fragmenting into different
parts of herself right that spirit's
control right and the male and female
which which is just anger
versus I guess more kindness and
stuff it's not even her voice man
that's a
demon
right now what does she have on her face
between her eyes she had like a look
like an hourglass or something it's
either I mean an hourglass or it looks
like a forever symbol Infinity sorry
infinity symbol so for the hermaphrodite
thing again when you Encompass both male
and female which she was obviously doing
with the um transgender colors mhm
sometimes that can actually be shown as
the infinity symbol as though both have
United oh wow
wow
okay so her eyes rolled back at that
moment did you notice how much she went
and just it was like all back like three
times and I was like okay so there you
go she's being possessed and she's happy
about it again she's just like
[Applause]
yeah oh so we got another character
coming in who's
that so this is the part that I believe
is supposed to be humorous although I
hate that they're covering it up as
humor
because I believe this is her furry
strange creepy new better boyfriend that
she's conjured up um which again when
you ask usually from Satan or the demons
for what you want you usually do get it
in a strange way H not what you really
wanted I'm not sure if I want to worship
Satan I think I'm happy to worship God
the Christian God of the Bible who gives
us a proper human being to be with right
and he just showed up out of nowhere
yeah just very creepily as
well oh and she went back to the moon
was her F friend chilling with her yeah
that she just evoked o oh stop stop okay
they actually had the words hudo oh okay
who do all the things that you do yeah
that's clever that is really clever
because another name for Voodoo is hudo
H so she's like she's practicing Voodoo
for one Witchcraft and Voodoo very close
together and then when you just use
Music especially tempos use tempos to
actually invoke that kind
of um weird pulsating of the body to
almost act like you've lost control
right that is voodoo so she's using the
word hudo so yeah that was very very
clever having fun with my demon friends
mhm
okay so she's saying for your romance
it's almost as though she's actually
singing about the demon or about Satan
okay so I would beg steal and borrow to
have that kind of romance is what she's
gotten to so far it's like her oath to
him slow dance me which again is it
sounds to me like a reference to what we
showed earlier dancing with the devil
which is a very common theme in the
Hollywood and the music industry in
references to Satan
and she's getting killed or something
he's taking control of her and like oh
we saw the same thing in the Life
performance yeah so he's turning on her
yes which is it is typical of demons you
guys you do not just follow around with
this stuff you don't follow and get what
you want without there being something
they want from you yeah don't don't do
it it's not worth it okay so what I was
seeing there is that he oh that Satan
will take away all your sorrow she was
seeing for your romance I will beg steal
and borrow and you'll take away all my
sorrow no he doesn't Okay so yeah that's
a lie for one but we usually do
gravitate towards things like drugs or
substances or even sex or music I'll put
that all out on the same table because
it is all substances you can use to turn
off your emotions of the guilt or shame
or even I don't know just Godly things
you're supposed to feel um that you're
turning off you're just like sedating
all of them yep so
so she she's get now she's getting fully
possessed as he is chasing her okay can
you pause that though so she almost
looked like she was crying which usually
it does it turns into like this terrible
Cry Cry of desperation like help me
they're controlling they're coming after
me yes they're same in life performance
yep and again from all of these
experiences that I've read about it's
the same thing it's like it doesn't
matter what I'm feeling at that point
it's taken over it's having its way with
me yeah and I have no control and
besides this whole scene is happening in
front of the moon at night so yeah dark
yeah there's the eyes again she said
abak kadava Okay and she says I speak to
destroy so they have a lot of actually
spells that are to destroy your enemy
which is what she sought to do yes but
she also seemed to be and I'm not trying
to give this information for promoting
it but they also have a lot of love
magic and love spells as well to get
back your exes or even bring about your
new husband or your new love so that
they are bound to you like spiritually
who wants to be in relationship with
someone that has just been forced to be
in your life mhm like why would you want
that MH God wants you to be bound
spiritually but it's a different way a
totally different way and it's he gives
us free choice yes and so they're
they're trying to impose their will and
I I know this for a fact because I've
done so much research on it she is when
you cast a spell or you manifest there's
actually no difference um and it's a
different definition in the Bible by the
way when we read manifest it doesn't
mean any of that when you do that you s
superimpose your will upon the universe
the god the Creator whatever you want
you're trying to get your will out of it
and make it happen right because Satan's
listening yeah to what you want when you
actually speak it yeah and so she's just
she's dipping into that but then it
backfires yes clearly always so don't
don't play with this stuff it's not
worth
[Music]
it oh there's her new boyfriend saying
hi hanging out with you in your
bed I find this interesting too uh I'm
thinking about uh uh I think it's the
end of the video but I'm thinking about
beastiality that she's clearly with some
kind of an animall likee person
uh and go God clearly says in his Bible
in his word that he speaks against that
do not get involved with beastiality so
she's promoting a whole slew of things
that the Bible speaks against in this
video any last thoughts no that that was
enough you know guys the reason why we
put this out here is not to entertain
you to give you any information about
well now I know a little bit more about
the occult or paganism we are showing
you this because we want you to
understand this is happening in the
world right this is happening in Europe
and this is happening in front of
millions of eyes there's children
watching this show
there this video has look how many
people how many subscribers uh uh views
1.9 million views like that is absurd
and she went through the H the
semi-finals with this song and you know
the way your vision song festival works
is that each country that's involved
with it that's part of the well Europe
has to decide there's a committee that
decides we are going to send this local
National musician that we have in our
country to participate in the Eurovision
song festival to hopefully win this
these music videos these artists these
this propaganda is being pushed out by
Satan not for no reason this doesn't
just happen if you have been watching
what's happening in the world and you've
been seeing more and more and more evil
I hope this is a wakeup call that
prophecy is being fulfilled that Jesus
is coming soon and that now is the time
to choose we cannot be dabbling in two
different sides anymore we cannot say
well I don't know I like this stuff
Revelation 2 and 3 read it it talks
about I will Jesus says I would that you
were either cold or hot but because you
are lukewarm I will spew you out of my
mouth because he's non I don't believe
that Jesus just sitting there being like
I want to spw you out of my mouth I
believe that the sins of the people who
are claiming to be Christians are
getting so high that it it has a
nauseating feeling on his stomach where
in there's a an act where he has to
vomit none of this is what he wants for
anybody right he says I want you to be
hot I want you to be hot because I'm
coming soon and in John 3:16 everybody
knows that um for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whoever believes in him shall not perish
but have everlasting life choose you
this day whom you will serve if me and
my house we will serve the Lord today
Choose You whom you will serve today
choose the Lord um while you know while
you hear the spirit speak to you and if
you hear the spirit convict your heart
that maybe this is not something you
should participate in and maybe you're
not even watching these kind of songs or
listening to this stuff but something um
I don't know like let's say Taylor Swift
We got a whole video on her I encourage
you to watch it um you know all these
other uh musicians that look at our
Channel and see which ones we've covered
right and look into these things do your
research and understand that maybe this
World Is Not What It Seems maybe there's
something more to it maybe there isn't a
severe attack on you as a person and on
the beautiful relationship God wants to
have with you
and maybe Satan is trying to do his
absolute best to keep you away from himh
so that you will not choose Jesus fully
wholeheartedly on fire hot for Jesus
like a blaze so that when he comes back
he says I don't have a choice I want you
on my side I want you be with me but I
cannot force you because you make your
own decisions cuz you have free will I
encourage you choose Jesus today and
I'll just add to that that I and I would
love for people to realize also that
music and media like this they're
obviously putting her out there to be in
public eye is it's not just randomly
chosen like you said y it is preaching a
message to you it's planting seeds it's
out there to actually get people
interested in this stuff in the occult
and move them um further on that
trajectory towards it and towards
accepting it because you become more
numb towards realizing it's evil so yep
so we can choose to either be numb mhm
and draw closer to to the dark side and
um this is what Satan does to people or
we can choose Jesus who saves us from
sin because he gave himself for
us um and in a way
that shows his love like nobody else
ever could
[Music]
[Applause]